well the new clark county school
district grading policy is leading to
fewer failing grades but more low grades
the policy went into effect
district-wide this school year after
previously being implemented at a
handful of schools in the valley kate
houston live in the studio to highlight
why teachers are concerned about the new
model
yes the school district says the goal is
to ensure students grades accurately
reflect their knowledge of a subject by
reducing the impact of non-academic
factors such as behavior but teachers
and students say the new priority on
testing versus assignments is causing
problems it's been really heartbreaking
there are three main changes to the ccsd
grading policy the lowest grade is 50
percent behaviors do not influence a
grade and summative assessments such as
a test are weighted far more than
assignments he gets great grades on the
assignments but then when it comes to
the test he has so far bombed every
single one harriet robinson says her son
has a d in math although some schools
are offering retakes robinson says it's
not allowing him to catch up by the time
he gets to the retake
that you know they've already moved on
in the lesson so he's he's trying to
remember something from the previous
week while also trying to remember what
he's currently learning del sol academy
teacher tam lester says they're
reporting less apps but there are far
more c's and d's while he's seen
benefits in the policy he wants more
resources for teachers it is a difficult
transitionary period for the teachers
because we don't have
a ton of different assessments prepared
we don't have the time for it right now
and we don't have the training lester
encourages families to connect with
teachers if they need guidance please
don't hesitate to communicate and
teachers are this is why we do the
career right
to be able to make impacts in people's
and families lives
well not all schools are allowing
retakes on assessments ccsd plans to
implement a consistent reassessment
policy next school year denise